hello thank you everyone for being here
my name is Santiago Dawa from Spain and
I'm security analyst working at risk EUR
today I'm going to talk to you about our
research on full injection on the motive
parts on the embed security world as you
may know there is a lot of automotive
security stuff going on since the 2014
thing with Charlie Mille doing all this
cheap hack that was really hitting hard
into the media and also some Tesla hacks
that were partly some time ago we can
also speak about control in devices on
the knees or using the apps that were
for Mitsubishi ok so what does it mean
hackers are getting interested into a
cars because every time cars are more
and more electronics and that's a good
thing to do so yeah we have electronics
on cars and the bad guys are taking
advantage of that we can see this kind
of stuff online like thing called
mileage correction it's more like yeah
well you know I drove like a hundred
thousand miles with my car by mistake
can you please help me correct that you
can also have some counterfeit pieces
for the aftermarket so your fancy car
can have actually contour fade pieces
because hackers are defeating the
protections against installing
non-official parts on cars if you saw
the like euro were around the car
hacking news nowadays most of the
attacks are based on this part of the
architecture if we log into a car and
all the different parts and services
related around that
we can call it core cloud services more
like yeah you synchronize your car with
the service online and you can see the
mileage you can see your fuel level
whatever all the access here we were
speaking about all the baseband and the
access to the network from the car the
car gateway your network there are a lot
of hacks around this I don't know if you
know the b2 or any other kind of attacks
using the campus directly but there's
not a lot going on on the ECU and even
lower on the MCU installing this ECU and
that's where we're speaking now our
riskier we thought so we have a lot of
know-how on sites annual analysis and we
have a lot of know-how in fall
injections so let's apply it to the
motive market let's start defining what
it's an ECU so this is you comes from
electronic control unit a decent
specifically is one that is in charge of
the engine injection airflow and all
that and in a generic way and easy uses
made of a non-volatile memory
communication interface is usually gone
flex right you have also automotive
Ethernet and then you have actuators and
sensors that interact with the rest of
the car our knack to it makes the thing
that you want to do with your car then
you have some RAM and then some
microcontroller or processor linking all
together easy use come in a lot of
shapes in a lot of forms they do a lot
of different things and we as
researchers as hackers we have the duty
of understanding we had the duty of love
them
so this is me this is my collection of
easy use on the lab and specifically
this project is about one of these
devices it's called an instrument
cluster you can also call it a dashboard
or the theme with the blinky lights
which so said because we had one run and
we thought it would be funny to mess
with it so yeah as we said in the
previous slide the ECE architecture is
not different from any other emmett
system so our path to break it or our
path to compromise it comes over these
these steps first we need to understand
the target we need to know how it works
what it does and then we try to identify
vulnerabilities on it once we find
vulnerabilities we exploit them but to
understand the target and being on a
blackbox fashion what we usually find
use is the finger because there's it's
convenient you have the finger it is
easier to understand what is going on
easy use are not standalone they are
connected on networks like this this is
a modern car our neck nor architecture
you can see here this is a gang gateway
here is our target the instrument
cluster but then you have all sorts of
easy use connected this is these are the
airbag systems body control module with
the lights everything and this looks
really nice you know clean tidy but when
you open the lid and give a look you see
the abysm this is just a part of the all
the wiring diagram of a car like that
document kept have like 2000 pages of
this debugging and diagnosing a car is
really hard
that's why clever people to me came up
with Diagnostics systems and we were
speaking here about unified diagnostic
services
from now on UDS this is an ISO standard
that is being built on almost every
vehicle right now and it describes
different services for Diagnostics data
transmission and perform security access
checks so there are some different
levels of privileges and a lot more of
stuff this is a list of different
services specified in UDS you can see
that there are a little bit of
everything you can establish a
diagnostic session you can see the the
travel codes you can read data like the
I don't know revolutions of the engine
stuff like that is like a diagnostic and
tracking services and then if we give a
look we have I know some of them are you
fact we can see some of them there are
really interested interesting in from a
security point of view remember you
address is a service that allows you to
retrieve the content the memory content
of a physical address this for here
request download upload data and
transfer and exit this for our part of
the ECU finger upgrade flow which is
also interesting if we want to extra the
finger remember we need something here
like this the thing is these services
are somehow protected by security axis
so security axis is a way that the let's
call it tester here is set as client but
the tester has to authenticate in order
to get access to these other services
that are more compromising for saying
this service has challenge-response
fashion in a way that decline or the
dester let's call it us
we request acid and the ECU generates
the C and calculates the response the
here is status key and the standards
also call a key but is kind of confusing
but the end is that will request a seed
the seed is generated the ECU calculates
a local key with that seed and since the
same seed that was generated an hour and
we should calculate the same key using
the same algorithm and send the key back
here this you will check that the
calculated key is the same as the
received and if it's the same do you get
access granted okay here comes the big
problem UDS does not give any kind of
implementation details or
recommendations they used tell you yeah
just follow this security access you
behave like this but there's no other
detail what happens with that but coding
practices and you know manufacturers
sometimes sometimes make errors and
let's try to find out what can go wrong
here I don't have it them here they're
on my backpack out but I got three
boards that risk your developed for
doing a harbor CTF coverage kirino's
from the Irate semi three I don't know
you are aware I'm willing to give them
away to the people that can tell me what
can go wrong here before I change the
slide on this topic there are no logical
flaws there are no or buffer overflows
there are no smashing stacks or nothing
is just what can go wrong in this here
if you got a bad design replay attacks
like like what you
okay but if you get a different seat the
replay is not the same so you cannot get
it but Google over there the okay that's
one of the other things the key
calculation algorithm being WIC
you got a board oh they're the key
verification I like that one we will
speak about that you can have one of the
words you say that's another one the key
space is too sure so you can just brute
force another board there are no more
boards re but we can keep going okay
yeah yeah that's that's another another
issue okay now that that's too too
complicated it's easier than that so I
will just keep now and you can see what
we came with I don't know if you agree
with this but this is all that can go
wrong with this thing if you don't
specify anything we can start with the C
generation you said some something
related to replace so you could actually
do a replay if you alter the random
number generation so you can do replace
here the poor algorithm I don't know who
mentioned that please look at me
afterwards so you can have the board if
the algorithm is poor like yeah the key
is just the seed plus one come on that's
that's easy it's more key space if it's
not really a lot of bytes you can
brute-force it key calculation you were
speaking about leakage but we are
speaking about disclosure
if there is a disclosure of the
algorithm although all the security here
is just this pre-shared secret which is
the algorithm if it's compromised if
it's disclosed the security's gone key
verification we were speaking about some
something about heating and jumping we
will speak about that but problem is
that there is no trial limit so you can
still perform perform some boot force
and also well this is not that important
but you can have security access but the
standard doesn't specify what kind of
services do you protect with this so you
don't actually need to protect anything
is if you don't want to and you can
still get your I don't know
stamp of saying yeah UDS compile and so
yeah for this we have some mitigations
we can apply secure coding practices as
always use a big space key and some big
space for the seed and the key use try
limit so you cannot brute force you we
can use unique keys that adds a lot of
value because at the end if you disclose
the algorithm it's gonna work for every
device that uses the same algorithm but
if we change to a scheme using unique
devices like unite keys per device it's
going to be better then this is a
mitigation around the cedar entropy
using algorithms that are strong and
proven and also another solution is
using offline like sorry online
calculation for them for the silence
response so now cars are connected to
internet is really most of the cars are
connected so you could decide to okay I
want to authenticate so you need to do
the calculations on a server and then
there is nothing going on the car so
it's a secure question
you think this is enough are these
enough mitigations is everything here is
salt if I use this dope because we still
have Howard attacks around this we can
use sites and analysis for disclosing or
leaking the the things are going on for
transforming the city into the key and
also over there you can use fall
injection to skip the key verification
i'm leaving the side channel analysis
for people or smother me and i'm
focusing on fall injection and that's
this talk so we're gonna now get a brief
introduction into a full injection full
injection parts from the idea of the
components having a safe operation
operation parameters so you have a range
of a voltage that you can apply and then
you have a range of clock speed and also
the parameters like temperature and i
don't know I'm not very pressure I don't
know but there are several parameters
that you need to fulfill to for the
device to work properly but what happens
if you go out of this of this stuff what
happens if you go around so if we're
speaking about Baltics I will introduce
you to the world of voltage creating we
can do over vaulting that means going
with the voltage higher than specified
we are going out of the safe operating
area by increasing the voltage but one
of the results is that if you over bolt
for a long time you burn the device on
the other hand you can do the opposite
you can under bolt you can pull the
voltage slower than the specified and
then get your revolting under bolting
the thing is most probably if you do it
for some time
the device will just power
but we want for doing voltage glitching
is doing it on an instant and in a
controlled way so if we want to do our
bolting glitching we just go with the
current voltage functional one and then
do a inject a glitz by over voltage in
but then going back to the to the phone
proper voltage and the the equivalent
but with underworld tipped usually we do
on the voltage okay so for doing this we
have different tools we have open source
tools like the chip whisperer hello
calling I don't know if here he was
really busy out but hello and we are
also commercial solutions like inspector
if I sell by my company riskier that if
you're interested you can just go to the
website so what happens when we glitz
things go wrong you're trusting your
right on your right level clock source
you're relying on a stable power supply
but what if this get compromised well
here with dragons there are a lot of
things that could happen when we glitz
this is gold fold modeling and it's just
like discipling on on its own starting
how the folds affected a target because
there's there are a lot of things that
could happen and let's let's see for
example you can flip bits during
injecting or glades on a device you can
flip bits and registers and yeah from
from both sides from 0 to 1 1 to 0 you
can also prevent the read and write of
registers on memory by glitz in the
pipeline flow you can skip instructions
as a sub like a derivate of
preventing reading so if you prevent
reading and your reading instruction
you're facing you can skip an
instruction and this is really useful
and you can also disable modules maybe
flipping a bit on the configuration
register or something but there is
another thing that could happen if you
let
you inject glitches and is that you
destroy your chip and that happens more
than you think okay so we have someone
on the bottom saying yeah we have the
key verification let's try to glaze it
so we are authenticated we we are
following our flow here and we reach the
key verification step here that will
look something like this the receipt key
is the one that I'm sending here the
spectacle is the one that we call the
ECU calculator here so the only thing is
going on is comparing and if you're if
not the same you're nothing to get it
else you're authenticating so we could
just glitz right we said okay we can
skip instructions let's keep this one
nope it happens to be that mitigation
works and there is some mitigation
suggested on the UDS standard saying
that some time delay may be required for
the security access service so if after
a defined number of false atoms yeah
like after number of false atoms you can
trigger like a timeout so sometimes need
to pass until your next authentication
patent on our target it was ten minutes
every three false admins and that's a
lot because if you want to do a fire and
you need to go actor eyes the the device
or do whatever every three atoms you
need to wait ten minutes you'll not take
too long so this mitigation really
mitigates fi attacks but a we have more
services if you remember we had this
read memory by address and here this
service is really really easy the client
asks sends a frame saying a give me I
don't know a hundred bytes from this
address and then these you text your
your security level and it looks
something like that there is a variable
something called authenticated meaning
if you passed or not the security access
before and here we're checking if you're
authenticated
you're not authenticated access denied
if you're out indicated access granted
here we could actually glitch here right
yeah here we can
there is no nope the good thing here
also is that there is no attempt limit
you can try this as much as you want if
you're authenticated the only thing is
the ECU is gonna return you negative
response so what we do is preparing our
full injection setup and try to glitch
this disservice the full injection
scheme something like this I am really
sorry that I couldn't bring this set up
here and do a light demo I have a video
I can show you now but before going
through the video we can go a little bit
through this we have our computer there
is connected to the spider spider is a
commercial name that we have for FB
fpga-based glitch in device this spider
is doing vault is glitching over a BCC
lying to the target and also controlling
the reason so every time that we try to
glitz will reset as well and then the
triggering and the target communication
is using this uragan uragan is also a
commercial name that we have for a tool
that like a can adapter that also has a
trigger functionalities and also fussing
and man-in-the-middle ink and networks
you can check it out it's really
interesting on our website the setup
looks something like this so this is a
spider this down here is the uragan this
was one of the first versions this is
just an oscilloscope but this is a glitz
amplifier that is required for doing the
voltage
most of the times and this is our target
with all the blinky lights and
everything and by the way this is more
like the setup that our salespeople make
ours looks more like this
we love for our laughs we like it nasty
and full of cables so if you want I can
show you now the video maybe
[Music]
so here's the computer there's no and
here we are running the the software
that controls the glitzen device and
also the yer account for communicating
the workflow is really simple we first
send the request for the memory and
after that command the uragan sends a
trigger line so the spider is ready for
greeting depending of our parameters you
can see here it's running and it's read
does several times per second read means
access glitz and green means back lights
this is the uragan so as to different
can interfaces so you can do like mine
in the middle connecting your target
here and the rest of the network here
and you can control the traffic that
goes from one side to the other you can
also power the target with this and has
also some no resistor for terminating
the canvas you can use it or not and
this is the trigger line that goes from
the european to the spider spiders
connected here here is receiving sorry
the here is receiving the minute yeah
here is receiving the trigger from the
european and then the spider is
connected to the glitch amplifier
directly to the target the target only
has this kind of connections is just
can't hike and lo mein bolted and ground
and then from here we have this line
that goes to the glitz amplifier is
providing directly the voltage for the
MCU this this power supplies for the
rack for the rest of the ECU so here
we're controlling the core MCU voltage
and this is the recent line there are no
further modifications on the on DC you
do you could install it back again to
the GABAA I wouldn't do it and that's
all
so going back to our presentation chip
go through it
this is like so sorry do you want a joke
or something almost there okay so that
was the setup more like this and then
for full injection we need to define the
parameters so we're Inglot seing a
voltage glitz and we are doing all under
voltage there are three different
parameters that we need for our
glitching camping one is the delay let's
delay is the time from trigger to the
actual glades would be this time this is
an d CC the scope capture this is time
voltage different signals okay so glitch
delay is the time from frontier to the
glades
obviously here our glitz delay should be
from this to this because we are sending
the common and authentication
verification takes place here before the
response so should we should lit
somewhere around here then we have the
glitch duration if we assume this glitch
here okay we have the the glitches has a
certain width we can control that and
that depends on how sensible the target
is to two glitches we need to we need a
wider or a shorter glitz and also the
voltage if we go with a more negative
voltage or less negative voltage so for
finding the right parameters what we do
is randomized is free for all we use set
some windows that according to our our
spirits and other things like I said for
the
glitch delay we define this time window
for the glitch duration abilities we
also have some
values that experience teaches how to
proceed and you just leave it for I
don't know a couple of days running and
then you get something like this I don't
know if any of you is familiar with this
kind of plots but for fall injections
are really useful in this plot every dot
is glitzen attempt and the color is the
what is the result of the attempt so in
red we are putting the expected result
like meaning that the glitz didn't have
any kind of effect on the target on
yellow we have the mute usually if you
glitz too hard the device reboots and
you don't have any kind of response from
it but then we have these little red
pills which are the success is something
that is not the usual response or a mute
and are also like the the expected
result that we have when we want glitz
so what we got here is that there is a
relationship between the voltage and the
duration here is and some parts are even
a linear relation so you can use that
for trimming we start with random
parameters randomizing them with really
huge limits from from you see here from
zero voltage to zero volts to two volts
but then you see that every item higher
the 150 is not doing anything and any
lower than all 50 that there is nothing
interesting here so you start trimming I
started out doing heat from here to here
and the duration the same do you get
your relationship and then you can
define an area in terms of voltage and
duration that gets a higher success rate
these plots are really useful but then
we have the so we had three parameters
remember both its duration and we'll
also have the glitz delight what happens
with a glitch
delaying why can we get a hundred
percent success rate this one word Jeter
as we said we have our common there is a
response and there is some time in
between that you need two blades but the
thing is they see you is built on top of
some wrong real-time or birthda system
of other application that has a
scheduler and the thing is that the
response may come in different at
different moments from the trigger there
is not a fixed time from from your
command and the response and that makes
it really hard because it's like
shooting to a moving target the respond
can end up here or here and maybe the
glitz point is not here now is it here
or maybe here depending on when the
respond comes but for causality things
you cannot predict what is coming so
that make it makes it harder and that's
why you still need the randomization you
cannot fix the parameters and get a
hundred percent success rate with this
kind of complex targets I think this is
blank because I was putting here the
video well you can stir at the infinite
okay
so wrapping up a little bit we could we
were successful on the on this attack
there are some highlights that I want to
present you this attack were we
performed them and they were working on
different ECU's it's at them designing
around different MCU so it's not a it's
not it's independent of the harbor that
you're using then we also use different
fi techniques here I explained to you
both the splitting but we were also
using EMF I using e/m pulses for
injecting volts and that was also
working it was really with more or less
the same success rate the
depending on the target its ECU
implements the read memory by address
service in a different way and we had
some targets that the maximum chunk of
memory that you can ask for was maybe
hundred bytes but then another one was
all only 40 bytes or something like that
so that is also a difference on
implementation because again UTS doesn't
specify what kind of parameters you
should accept it's up to the
manufacturer and then as a result we
could extract the complete viewer in
order of days in all the targets well it
will be more or less depending on the on
the device because it's MC you add a
different memory content I mean memory
sizes on the internal memory and this
kind of attacks and that's why we want
to stress here has consequences most of
the people say that fi is hard to scale
I get it you cannot go to a car and you
know starting delete glitching directly
to the car and then run on it it's not
feasible you need a lab you need time
but the consequence is the things that
you can get from the from from this fi
attack has this kind of consequences you
can get AI be stealing automotive
manufacturers are really worried about
this because you're spending a lot of
money in time resources for getting your
IP working like your abs algorithm or
your control loops made on software that
cost money that cost time and if I'm a
competitor I can just subscribe your
finger and steal it we can speak about a
de-escalation but it's known on the next
slide I'm more thinking about finger
modification you can modify the finger
remember when I show you the table with
services there is another one called
write memory by address I don't know if
you can imagine what you can do with
that you can write on any physical
address so you can patch the finger you
can write into ROM and then get some
contribution and you can do a lot of
nasty
with this you can do so - you can do
tuning you can do whatever and on the
tag escalation part if we get the finger
and we got it reversed we can find
exploits on that finger we can also
extract the secrets contain contained on
that finger like this UDS security
access algorithm that we were talking
about you can instructed you can extract
the keys used for the finger upgrades
that usually come encrypted and all
these furthermore can be distributed you
can distribute the finger I can do all
the Fi and then give the finger to the
some rational forum for them to reverse
the secrets can also be distributed
vulnerabilities and exploits you can
also distribute them and that's
dangerous and if we ripe up wrap up
we're here to say that UDS is vulnerable
it's not that UDS is vulnerable but the
implementations of duteous are not
really good because they lack for
example and from our perspective as
attackers interested or proficient in fi
techniques there are no resistance power
or software in in automotive the also
that we saw that just the security
access description has also some flaws
as we were saying all this key space is
not specified so they don't encourage
security on the own standard and then
fall injection is relevant for for
automotive it's up available to the
masses you can glitch with open-source
tools like tip whisper or if you're more
a more committed attacker and you need
the I don't know you can get more
professional tools and just glit the
out there easy use fall injection
messes
with your security on software you think
everything is secure because you don't
have a logical flaws and all that but
fall ingestion
fall injection can defeat that you can
inject false and you can get the femur
out of the thing that was designing for
not getting the thing without so check
out as we said is not an affecting just
an ECU it's a thing that is shared among
different issues and we did this attack
on different models run in UDS and also
as we discussed we can escalate the
attacks from the FI last but not least I
want to thank my colleagues Nick ELISA
and Ramiro for giving me a handful with
these lights and talk and everything
else I can share this and we have some
white papers around all this that you
can check and that's all if you have any
questions or I'm here to answer just a
thing the longer it takes the longer the
picture stays have one question
yeah when we look at a smart card code
like for instance verifying a pin which
is a very simple thing looks extremely
ugly when it becomes fault resistant
because you know we have to consider a
number of faults in there so there lot
of things happening so how can we do you
see how we can extend this kind of
protection - well I wish very complex
software like okay we're speaking on
software
yeah what's the impact of protecting for
from your point of view for protecting
against these attacks on I would say
complex firmware like you can find in
easy to use well the thing is that
actually the the software running on the
ECU is more different tasks that's what
they use a real-time operating system
they are the different tasks that they
need
perform and there are some critical that
they need to be really fast but then
there are others that even though you
add your protection and mitigations the
performance doesn't get affected there
are a lot of techniques for protecting
software against a full injection like
doing a bullet I'll text and
double-checks doing checking the loop
variables when you finish the loop
things like that if you start thinking
about how many instructions you can skip
you can build around that you can build
new text and if you check that something
is going wrong you can reset or do
something about that
so yeah you can actually implement
control measures but I agree that they
don't look nice when you see the code
it's gonna be fun next question is
because of the picture I can take it off
they weren't gone there all right thank
you for you talk thank you
[Applause]